good evening a lot of questions
surrounding the golden knights tonight
after covet protocols kept them from
talking
after the game thanks for joining us i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis the
knights topping the ducks inside
t-mobile but both teams canceled
post-game availability
sports director chris matthews here now
with more on what is a developing story
chris
yeah it's developing right now we're
awaiting word from the vegas golden
night shay theodore played
even assisted on a goal and then left in
the second he didn't return
tomas nosick also left he didn't return
what's got everybody's attention now is
what transpired after the game the
knights canceled the post game
press conferences no players no coaches
they said it was because of covid
related protocols
that's been over 90 minutes ago at last
check no official word from the knights
but
vegas could get dinged with more covet
issues they've already had three games
canceled
trying to fight that virus as vegas's
biggest battle
let's show you what unfolded quickly
before all this happened in
vegas took a three-goal lead into the
third but the ducks would score three
goals on three shots on goal and it's
tied
but then zach white cloud comes in to
save the day he scores at 3 56
of the third vegas wins it 5-4